une petite danse d'accueil de la part
des anciens élèves toutes les
générations sont à l'honneur pour fêter
40 ans d'existence d'une école qui a
accueilli près de 1000 élèves une grande
réunion de famille en quelque sorte
c'est vrai que c'est agréable ce sera
même en rire tu ses souvenirs tu te ses
sorties scolaires etc
vous êtes restés dans la région pas du
tout moi oui je suis resté à 120 sandra
n'irai donc je revois encore certains
qui sont restés ici mais bon y'a pleins
par la force des choses qui sont partis
ce genre grade de les revoir
quatre décennies d'enseignement autant
de photos de classes de sorties
pédagogiques que les anciens élèves
retrouvent avec nostalgie
on a passé de bonnes années et voilà la
vie continue maintenant c'est nos
enfants savent et nous nos petits
enfants dans quelques années ça me fait
pas peur
qu'est-ce qu'on peut changer 500
personnes se sont déplacées à l'occasion
de cette grande kermesse une rencontre
entre les générations et aussi de beaux
souvenirs en mémoire celle déjà d'un
formidable
oui et puis
je sais pas c'était c'était tellement
convivial quand les gens quand les
agriculteurs tuer les cochons à cette
époque et il m'apportait un petit port à
leca morceaux de boudin le groupe
scolaire maurice nul ne pouvait pas
accueillir tous ces anciens élèves faute
de place il fallait bien plus d espace
pour un tel événement une célébration
pour souhaiter une longue vie à l'école
de saint vincent brazon
[Applaudissements]